[MUSIC PLAYING]
When it comes to
performance, there's
some stuff you can
control, and then there's
other stuff that you just have
to be aware of and work around.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And CPU frequency scaling is
one of those harsh realities
of mobile development that
you can't control, but can
have a significant impact
on your application.
See, in order to
conserve battery,
Android devices can
reduce the amount
of voltage supplied to the CPU.
This means that the processor
will draw less energy
to execute code, with the
side effect of slowing down
your CPU in the process.
Essentially, your code
will take longer to run.
And this is a very
regular occurrence.
Your Android device
is constantly
trying to throttle
voltage to the CPU
to save as much
energy as possible.
The interactive CPU
governor that Android uses
constantly checks
the CPU workload
to determine if the
frequency can be scaled back
or if it needs to be ramped up.
The ramifications of such
are a little weird to you,
as a developer.
Firstly, when the
frequency gets throttled,
you'll notice that normal
operations take longer
to execute.
So don't be surprised if,
suddenly, your frame time
spikes start to shoot
above 16 milliseconds.
And secondly,
changes in frequency
take about 20
milliseconds to occur,
meaning that if you come right
out of a low-frequency state,
the first frame of rendering
may be slower due to the fact
that the CPU hasn't had
a chance to ramp up yet.
In general, you need
to remember that this
is working as intended.
A battery is everything
on mobile development.
And to the Android system,
it does a really good job
of balancing processing
speed versus battery
drain on your
behalf, so you really
don't need to worry about it.
And in fact, there's
a whole bunch
of things it does to
avoid this problem,
where performance is
critical, like bringing
the frequency all the way up
as soon as the user touches
the screen.
But other times, like if
you're using a service
or responding to an event,
you can see these issues
manifest themselves.
Just keep in mind that if you
start seeing frame rate spikes
or things taking longer than
they should be for no reason,
that frequency use scaling
could be the culprit.
To confirm this, you can
run a Systrace profile,
enabling the CPU frequency flag.
You'll notice a
nice bar at the top
that details what the
current frequency values are,
so you can see
how, overall, it's
impacting your performance.
And performance is all
about understanding
what the hardware is doing
and how your code should
react accordingly.
In this case, there's not
really much you can do.
But in all the other cases,
there's a ton of things
that you can work on.
So make sure you check out the
rest of the Android Performance
Patterns videos.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ community for other
great tips and tricks.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]